downright refused to die anywhere else  170 people were killed in a cyber psycho  attacks  listen kid  there's one thing i can tell you about  this city  you either love it  [Music]  or want to burn it  [Music]  no middle ground  coming here is a crash course in the  survival of the fittest  the greediest  the most vile  and most corrupted dogs see this badge  that means i can do whatever the [ __ ] i  want  but behind the blinding lights and all  the rot you might just discover a beauty  that can only be found here  night city is full of love  friendships  and family ties that run deeper than any  cyberware eddies can buy  zapper dumples and filth  in some ways night city never changes  [Music]  not everyone's buying it  but if you want to know for sure you  just need to try it for yourself  you